uh what is rust rust is intended to be a
language
a system programming language focused on
running blazingly fast so it's highly
optimized it also is supposed to prevent
segfaults this is something that most
programmers encounter when you program c
or c plus plus
and it should also guarantee three
thread safety so it has a threading
model that is supposed to be safe
the guiding principles are safe by
default so
there are essentially no undefined
behavior it does not require a run time
this is
not entirely true but this is what they
pitch
and it's also supposed to bring you
memory safety without using a garbage
collector
most languages that has memory safety
has some sort of garbage collector java
go r2
rust doesn't
so the language features the first one
is a very
well defined ownership system so we will
go over this briefly in in the rest of
the presentation
but that is one of the key features for
rust
the other thing is it has a very
powerful type system as i mentioned i've
learned a number of languages before
scheme and haskell are some of those
and this type system reminds quite a lot
of the type system of haskell it's very
similar in many ways
it has also picked up a few other
features namely hygienic macros if
people are familiar with that it comes
from scheme scheme r6 if i remember
correctly
which is a way to generate macros that
don't have
these problems with symbols
being
introduced that are not
well
macros can be a mess so
this solves this
you also have parameterized types and
traits which is sort of a replacement
for classes in
in comparison to c plus plus
it has support for asynchronous
programming so you can have
various ways of
having a engine that has several threads
being driven by
several
threads so we have a runtime that
actually can can juggle many things at
the same time this is mostly of interest
when you have i o bound
uh system
so in those cases you usually wait a
long time you have a
thread waiting for i o in the meantime
you can have the cpu doing something
else and there are asynchronous models
for this
and it is well defined in the language
it has as i mentioned a powerful macro
system i won't cover it here but it's
it's something that can offer both
significantly simpler models for
programming as well as good performance
so it's well worth to study
and you also have an ffi a forum
function interface to be able to
interface with c and similar things this
is necessary because one of the focus
areas is actually embedded systems and
that's also part of the reason why they
didn't pick a
or they wanted to avoid having a big run
time so
c is sort of pitched as not having a run
time rust is pitched as not having a run
time in a similar way it's not entirely
true but
it's trying to become as a small runtime
as possible
the history so this started in 2006 by
graydon [ __ ] he worked at mozilla at
this time it was just an idea something
he sort of played around with
after a while mozilla realized that they
had problems with their their
systems and they needed something better
so they got involved and started
adopting this language as a an
alternative to c2c actually
and the first stable release was
released in may 2015 and we had a
transition to a more modern version of
rust in december 2018
and right now we're roughly at
release 156 so it's
advancing quite fast
it is efficient
this is a comparison i of course i've
picked the best examples so there are a
lot of other things this is the
benchmark game if you're familiar with
that so it has a number of different
benchmarks it's it's a few simple
examples i picked the best ones i have
to admit that
but as you can see when you compare rust
with c and c plus plus they are on par
sometimes rust is a little faster
sometimes rust is a little slower but cc
plus plus and rust are roughly at the
same level when it comes to execution
and then we have the other category go
and java are quite similar in execution
time in these cases
and this is what people usually expect
so it shouldn't come as a surprise
the tooling we have is not it's it's
somewhat limited not right now but there
are a few good things there is a project
manager called cargo
uh there is rust code formatting and
other similar tools that help you with
this so you have clippy you have rust
formatter for this
and you also have a rust language server
that can index your code so you usually
can jump jump around among the code and
figure out where things are where you
have definitions where you have
declarations and similar things
rust library support it's
exists it has a very large body of
libraries roughly 67 000 last time i
looked
it grows all the time
it's called
cargo
it's called
crates crates dot io
some notable examples are cerde which is
done for serialization and
desterialization mainly to when you want
to send things over the network
you have daiso which integrates with
databases so you can have an arm layer
you have tokyo which is the biggest
library right now to use the
asynchronous model for programming and
it's an event-driven platform
it's quite efficient actually
and then you have hyper and rocket which
are intended for http
so this is
a few examples but there's a lot more
server sorry
no
it's not it's actually a library that
knows htv http
yes so
rocket for instance that's the web
framework where you can build servers it
uses hyper
for that
so where rust shines these are my my
ideas are where rust shines first of all
it's safe by default so when you write a
program when you get it to compile it
usually works and that's actually quite
amazing
the ownership model which keeps track of
where you lose where you own stuff and
where you don't own stuff and complains
when you are
leaving things without actually
being allowed to do that it's
very picky that's one thing
but it's actually one of the reasons to
why when you once you make it pause it
actually works
it has a powerful type system as i said
it's similar to haskell which is a
functional language
it's
it's amazingly powerful i i
i basically love it so
i would like to see something like this
in all languages
concurrency without fear is something
they pitch and that is because when you
are dealing with concurrency then you
have the problem with sharing objects
and this is controlled through the type
system so you can't by mystic share
things that aren't supposed to be shared
you can't by mistake forget to add a
mutex or have data that is not protected
by mutex it's it's in the design of the
library
and it uses the type system to make this
possible
it has no runtime it's sort of not
entirely true but it's a very small
runtime
so
this is one of the features especially
since you're focusing on embedded
systems
governance it's open source license mit
release train model is a six week cycle
nightly is built every night you can
test it and people do
you pick a beta every six weeks and you
test that more thoroughly
and then after that you cut a stable
from the beta assuming everything is
fine and then you have a new version
this is why it's constantly improving
all the time so you fix bugs you add
features
and you do a lot of other things as well
it has a very transparent language
development model it has a bunch of rfc
so if you have an idea you propose an
rfc this is debated publicly
and
usually
an agreement is reached on how it's
supposed to work
every year the rust governance actually
picks a project plan a roadmap for the
year by taking the the rfcs that seems
to be most mature and build a roadmap
for the year and then people work on
that one so it actually works quite well
so this was a brief introduction so do
you have any questions about these
introductory parts
i've read that they're like
very high quality but is there anything
or all of them is there anything to
ensure the quality or can anyone make
great anyone can make it great there's
actually
some squatting in the
environment as well people that pick
library names
add some basic implementation and don't
evolve it so that happens as well
those that are popular are high quality
usually but it's it's i mean it's 67 000
crates anybody can create one there is
no
limitations but
people are actually uh
usually investing time in making them
good and but there are a few that are
sort of left behind and in some cases
people are not maintaining things so
that's that's quite common as well
you had a question
from
language specification it's just rc
um there is a language specification i'm
not sure what you mean it's not
it's not that detailed as c plus plus
standard is but it there is a language
specification
yeah yeah so it helps so it's like java
more or less it's
one entity
there are some people working on an
alternate implementation okay
one based on ecc
okay interesting yeah i didn't know that
actually so i'm not keeping tabs on that
so
okay
so
do you have a question
yeah i saw the no run time
and you said it
so you don't if you run a very basic
program in in some cases you actually
need some basic machinery to actually be
able to run the library run the entire
program uh memory allocation is one
thing um
a few other things as well and in many
cases some languages have a very heavy
runtime java for instance it has garbage
collection is necessary
and there are a few other things that
are needed that are not part of the
library
and rust aims to avoid these runtime
these basic necessities that you need to
actually start and run the program
c has a similar model it has a very
small runtime i think there are a few
things that are actually necessary but
it's not much
cpr plus is a little larger but it still
has a few things that you actually need
whatever you do
okay what's the example of
things that restaurant time does
um
sorry i i don't know
it it's there it's it's something small
but it's very lightweight like
yeah
i think i know it's basically the main
thing it has to see nothing is slack
binding
so it's like
when like it panics the rust code you
can get the slack crates uh yeah that's
true
um yes that makes sense
no that's true so you can actually get a
stack trace if it panics yes
i guess that could be part of the
runtime yes um when you look at the
timing benchmarks between
customers
how much in the differences can you
attribute to language design versus
compiler optimizations
i think a lot of it has to do with the
actual implementation so i i can't
really uh
i i there are advantages to rust but i
don't think the rust language in itself
makes things faster it's just that the
compiler is very good it has a very
powerful time
much system type system the corporate
can
you can assume things that the c plus
plus yeah
yes it can that is really used because
it comes in fair that there is always
rules they can do
like uh
like alexis cannot assume that two
points yeah but there's lots of coding
but there are bugs in lvm so they can't
use that optimization
they haven't re-enabled it just now and
they're just waiting for a new bug for
this gallery
yeah so everything in rust is currently
built on llvm so which is the client
framework so
[Music]
but there is a gcc version
apparently ongoing so
so let's focus a little more on rust
actually this was a brief introduction
on on
what surrounds rust but let's go and
look at a few examples of problems in c
and how rust intend to solve them or or
how a rust attempt to solve
so the first one is actually implicit
conversions
so if you look at this example then we
have a an a cos a cosine minus one it's
supposed to return pi
and a
uh echoes archicos actually returns a
double
but since it's implicitly converted to a
float
you get a rounding error and this is
pretty close to pi
but it's not
particularly close would you discover
this is a problem
i don't think so i i couldn't see that
at first
but it's so close that you you don't see
it immediately
yeah
or 26 instead of yeah yeah makes sense
[Laughter]
so it's pretty close and and i mean in
in most cases you actually have warnings
for this so if you're trying to do an
implicit conversion if you have a double
to float or if you have
an entity or a long-term int or
something like that you can enable
warnings and you can turn this on in
gcc for example i usually use that and i
use dash w error as well to make sure
that i don't have warnings but
usually when i arrive to a new code body
i have a bunch of warnings people have
loads of warnings and they ignore them
so the question is have you enabled this
in your build do you compile with
warnings do you think warnings are okay
or not
i if you think warnings are okay and if
you have languages where or
implementations where you accept
warnings then you might not discover
this problem
if you do something similar in rust and
this is rust then you get a get an error
so it says basically okay i'm trying to
declare a variable here that is f32 a
floating bit 32
it says that a cosine
that version of it returns a
float64 that's not allowed you're trying
to make a conversion that could lose
data
not allowed so it gives a warning gives
an error sorry and don't compile
and this is the first example of a rust
program as you can as you can see it's
quite similar to to c how do you do it
if you want to want it
you can do an explicit conversion so you
can type as f 32 so there are costs but
you have to be explicit about it
and we should talk about uniform
initialization
uniform initialization in curly braces
sorry
ah okay that's
that's a good use
dangling pointers second one this is
quite common
and if you do this in c
well
in this case i usually get errors
because i have everything turned on so i
get an actual error on this one but as i
said not everybody does this if you try
to
return something that is actually
allocated on the stack in this function
and you try to assign to it you you're
likely to get a segmentation fault
unless you're lucky
so this is quite common compiler one
style so usually i get warnings for this
and i don't make that mistake or rather
i make that mistake but it doesn't go
into production so
if you do this in
rust instead
this is not really possible in rust
that's one of the things because rust
don't have pointers in the same sense as
c has
so i i've taken some shortcuts here
and i'm actually declaring a function
that returns a reference to a
an integer that is placed in global
memory
so that's what it means to be static in
this case but it errors out
so it's not identical to the program but
it's close enough at least and you get
an error here saying that hey you're
trying to return something that actually
is local here and it will be destroyed
here so
not allowed
questions have you made this mistake any
time
me too and i still do it so
use after three
this is a quite common problem and i
i've run into this in in
very strange ways occasionally i mean
this is a very easy example sometimes
you have these double deletes happening
or you have a use after after a delete
actually accidentally because you didn't
think about the destructor running or
something like that that can happen
the previous examples generated a
warning i tried to get this to generate
warnings it didn't i tried to turn on as
many
flags i could in gcc and i couldn't
actually get it to generate a warning of
any sort
so it pauses and it actually works when
you run it
most of the time but not every time
okay
there are a number of you have were you
thinking about asan or something like
that no they just introduced some
warnings
okay
probably taken from rust actually so
i've seen some some
cross pollination between c plus bus and
rust actually so they are introducing
things from each other
okay
i wonder why actually
um so this is actually a case where and
i can't write a programming rust for
this it it's not possible so i mean i
can't do this because there is no such
thing as an explicit delay the only
chance you have this run is with
sanitizer builds yeah so if you use asan
or something like that you'll we will
discover it
another thing that actually is quite
common this is
an easy example you can test this at
home so
iterators if you use iterators on a
vector that's fine you create a vector
you push something back on it then you
take a
a reference to the first one you take an
iterator pointing to the first element
keep that around you need to do
something with it
and then you push back another element
everything should be fine right
no
pushback
can actually invalidate the
iterator
but it doesn't have to
so your test might run fine
but when you suddenly start to actually
deploy this you will have
nice random
crashes
and the problem here is that at this
step here you take the iterator but once
you push something back
the vector might be too small for this
memory so it has to reallocate a new
chunk and move it somewhere else but
this pointer still points to the
original memory
which is released
and then this attempt will point to
memory that doesn't exist or isn't
allocated i should say it still exists
of course
doing something like this in rust on the
other hand actually generates an error
so you have the same semantics for
vectors in rust as you have in the c
plus plus there is no difference if it
grows too large you move it actually
but it complains and it says
hey
you're pushing something here and now
you're taking immutable but this is not
allowed because it could potentially
move i don't know for sure
because it doesn't look ahead
but it says that at this point you are
taking a reference to something that
could potentially move so you need to be
careful
and it actually generates an error
because it can can
later discover that this will actually
create problems
so for us this
fails it doesn't compile
but only if you push the second
uh yes
no not necessarily if you do something
in between that could potentially change
it it could fail but if you don't do
this push it will actually work fine
yeah sort of if the element is not used
then it still gives an error because you
have a reference to something that could
be used
so it actually generates an error anyway
it could say that this is defined but
not used so
i could ignore this error but it doesn't
at this point
so this is an another example of where
it tries to do this tries to avoid
these kinds of problems and
there
was the error here above latia what's
that
that error
yeah what exactly would it say
oh i had it actually here below but i
removed it it says exact words it says
something like owner you're you're
violating ownership rules i think it
says
there you have the ownership yeah yeah
something like that yeah now you can't
say that foreign
and the second push so this one is
called those two means that it tries to
access the same variable in two ways
yeah so this one
between those three yes yeah so this is
called the borrow it borrows a reference
to a position so it says hey i want to
borrow this because i might want to read
this one
and then later you actually put either
push or create plane if i use just one
of those lines the compiler will see
that i'm only using one of the
references i'm making and it will be
okay yes the thing is that music try to
use both references
you're trying to use it in two different
ways
yeah you're trying to use it in two
different ways here you want to read it
and that is a borrow but you can only
have
one mutable borrow
and any number of uh immutable borrows
and this is a immutable borrow but once
you start to actually take a mutable
borrow which means i want to change this
it says hey you're trying to get a
mutable borrow but this one says you
already want to read it so that's not
allowed forbidden and if you change the
order then you're also good
yes you should be good i move one line
of the two of the last two lines i
remove either one of them i don't get
snare
that's true yeah
so i'll cover the rules later so
i'll give you concrete examples this is
more focused on giving examples of how
it how it actually behaves in comparison
to c plus
so
rust's way to address this is no
implicit conversions that's one of the
rules uh some safe exceptions exist you
can
if it's safe it allows certain cases
no unsafe pointers you have a
way to get out of this checking by
calling calling unsafe code
we are not considering unsafe code here
can i do that with anything unsafe code
yeah
basically
so unsafe code also have pointers so you
can actually manipulate c pointers it's
intended mostly for interfacing with c
or other libraries
but that means it doesn't have any null
pointers either so
by default russ doesn't have null
pointers it doesn't exist
uh no explicitly allocations
you can't delete something you can't
explicitly deallocated it's not entirely
true as
you will discover if you dig into it but
basically you can't have explicit
allocations
but there is no garbage collector
and the key to this is the ownership
semantics so it has a number of rules
saying how you can borrow and reference
stuff
so that you don't have race condition
that's the key point and that's how
it tries to solve this
normally when you move things around
when you pass variables to functions you
use move semantics so you move things
into a function and it stays there if
you want to do pause it back you move it
out again
you can copy and copy means bit voice
copy you can also clone which means do
whatever you like
but by default you have very strict
ownership semantics if you clone
something of course you can pass that on
to somebody else
kind of a yes
reference calling yes
kind of it's not actually a reference
counting but it's it has a very set of
strict rules that sort of is more strict
than necessary
but it doesn't have to use reference
counting
i'll come to them so
and then you have this concept of
immutable immutable borrows and a very
annoying borrow checker if you go into
stack overflow you will see my
complaints about
things that i couldn't make work
and this is basically the borrower
checker complaining about stuff and i
have no idea what's going on so i'm
trying to ask on stack overflow and
people say hey
it's obvious or sometimes they'll say
that's interesting i didn't realize that
was a problem
so
well if you want to have fun you can go
look there so
now we're going to go and introduce a
little rust and try to to discuss the
the basics of rust this is quite a lot
so it's more slides than necessary
and i don't think i can cover everything
so i'll probably cut short but the slide
will makes the slice available somewhere
so you can look at them later if you
want
here's a starting example just to get
the basics of rust so you declare
functions with fn here's the dot product
you have a for loop you see the range
there you have a range operator you can
create a range going from zero to the
length of something
you can do some indexing on two arrays
here you have two vectors that you pass
in vectors consist of floats
and then i can create two vectors and i
can just
do a dot product of them and print the
result so
uh i'll give you a chance to ask
questions if there's something that you
think is odd
i'll explain more so
yeah not odd but what is it if the
second array or the vector has less
elements does it panic and exit or it
doesn't
well in this case i actually go through
the number of elements in the first one
but here's a case where it actually can
panic if you try to reference a vector
sorry this would run time
yes it would run time panic
it would run time panic if the later
vector is shorter so you should have
some error checking here
yep is the type of result inferred
directly or is it because uh
yeah it's just zero that zero which is
what 64 by default sorry i didn't guess
so result but the return type
yeah content the return type is
result
so the variable result the type of
result
from the type of the function yeah it's
inferred so
there is type inference inside rust and
that's actually very powerful so you can
give a type i did that in the previous
example but you don't have to usually so
it figures it out itself it actually
looks ahead in the program as well
yeah this is making copies of the raises
no it moves them
yeah
so it moves them into
so when you pause it in here if you were
to do something afterwards i'll show you
an example if they wouldn't exist
so
when he said like no explicit
allocations
that doesn't include like a drop point
where you pass your variable
you can actually drop it but
that's this is very rare and special
case normally you actually drop them
automatically
if i print next after this straight line
i get an error
you get a compiler yes because yeah
because x doesn't exist after that it's
passed into the function it belongs to
the function you can't read it
understood correctly you yeah that uh
it's gonna bounce check the y you know
square bracket i every single iteration
right it will do that yes but it will
panic if it it overflows so what if i'm
really interested in performances i
don't want to actually bounce check
every time is there any other type other
than vector which does not offer
then you invoke unsafe code and you use
pointers and you can do that
so but that's unsafe code i think it's
worth pointing out that the compiler
could probably tell and just do one
launching before like hoist the bunch up
in this case
it's very efficient the optimizer is
very good at figuring things out
um
like
i'm not sure the compiler is panicked
consistent it sounds strange
keep the panics in good place make sure
to panic when you should panic i wonder
if that is a good optimization anyway
yeah
so um there are a few things that rust
has that doesn't exist and which are i
think is actually quite cool
enumerations for instance it's not like
c plus plus enumerations or zero
numerations it's more similar to haskell
data types actually
so you have an enumeration which is a
constant but you can have parameters to
it as well this is really cool when you
build an interpreter for example i want
to have various clauses with ad model
div whatever so it's actually quite
useful
in c plus plus you would use something
like enum plus a struct plus union
perhaps or you could use a clause
and have a hierarchy of them that that
would work as well but this is quite
easy to use and quite cool actually in
my mind
here's an example of using a
enumerations it actually has pattern
matching so if you have something of
type error the previous one you saw you
can actually match it and then you can
say if i got an aborted i do something
in this case i i return the string
aborted
if it was not found then i can actually
take that parameter k and build a string
from it and return that so it's actually
quite convenient to use when you build
systems i like this kind of model of
working
yes it's a variant that's entirely
correct
and that's from haskell originally
actually so
you see they steal from each other's all
of them
so you usually only include
[Music]
other things
when you need them like that
use error sorry to use error you do it
inside a function instead of uh on top
like in
c plus plus yeah you can
you should do it locally like that when
you can
you can do that if you want to so it has
local variables in the same sense
here's something that is built in
this is an enum it is an option so this
is how it avoids actually using a null
pointer so it has something called an
option and this exists in c plus as well
std option
optional i think it's called right
somebody's good at c plus plus here so
it's optional right
and it has either some value or it has
no value so this is how you use instead
of having a null pointer you have
options
but it takes a type as well so it has a
type parameter
so you can accept anything it can be an
option of int it can be it can be an
option of you size in this example i
have below or anything else
so it has sort of templates you also
have template functions so you can have
an index function that can work for any
type t so you can have template generic
functions for
as well
as generic types
and this is just an example here you
have a function taking a
having a type parameter taking a vector
of something and returns
whatever that is it could be an index if
it wants to return an index a position
where it's found for ex for example
and here you see a special type called
the reference type so this is what rust
has instead of references i'll
cover this in just a few slides
another type that is built in and also
has special support is the result type
so you have no exceptions at all there
is nothing like that you actually have
result types instead which is a way to
say
you either return a correct result that
is an okay result or you return an error
they have different types
this is coming from more or less haskell
as well it's called a moan out there
where you can return either a actual
value or a an error something that
aborts
and this is an example so in this case
we have a function that takes a file
name
and a pattern it actually takes
two strings or references to strings
one is the pattern one is a file name
and it returns
essentially all lines matching that
pattern
and in this case i open the file
i read the files
and then i i look and see if i can find
a substring containing that pattern and
if so i push it and then i return
everything at the
end one thing that russ does is it
doesn't require
return the last value in the function is
actually the return value so you can
skip the return but return exists if you
want to return early
yes the length does let line equals a
read question so yes that means that
read might fail
what is read
yes i'll that is actually the result
typing effect so what happens is when
you iterate the file lines
you are going through you're creating an
iterator and the iterator returns a
result each time the result can either
be a line
or
an error
and the question mark operator basically
does this it says if it was an okay
result
take that and give it back
if it was an error return
the error upwards
so this is a shorthand for actually
being able to take the line and process
the arrows you can chain this quite
quite heavily it can become very
unreadable but this is how you handle
the results so it's an implicit return
there returning case of error
essentially
and otherwise it's just get the value
more questions then how does it work
over the stack i mean
now this function can return an error
do the functions above then also have to
consider that they can get either
a result
or an error
they can get a result the result can be
an okay value or an error but yes they
have to consider that
the calling function it infers it yes so
everything is type same function knows
like a compiler knows about all the
contents of the functions yes
no just the types just the it was
looking for return types or requests for
lambdas but not for functions you see
the exclusive result
it's given here a result can have errors
yeah so result can be two things
otherwise
yes correct so you have to have a result
type return type to use the question
mark operator
yep
all those two tags that you're playing
error how does it know which one is the
error i mean e-r-r is just a name that
you've chosen so which one is mapped to
the question mark or is that part of the
language this this is built in so the
question mark expands to a match clause
that matches either okay and then return
the actual value inside it
or executes a return with the error so
this specific type
is part of the language
this one yes yes the question marks
for the option and uh yes
so this question mark on the left line
you could read
a line in the code it's just an
error out if there is a line so it
doesn't take into account the previously
found results in the vector right
sorry say again i didn't know we assume
we have pipelines in the first three
lines we got the pattern but on the
fourth line we had an error
yeah so then it returns the error but
not that reviews the font patterns i'm
just trying to understand what the yeah
is doing so it's a return error then the
okay result will not will be just lost
right yes exactly because it saves
everything in a vector yeah and it here
it will return
here because
expands to a an actual return statement
yes what is e
e
uh it's an e type so you have two types
t and e t is the type e is the error
type
sorry
ah sorry um i haven't added it it's
quite common to actually redefine the
result type in the package so you have a
default error for the package
and i
missed it there so i should actually
have it there as well
it should be compatible with whatever is
expected
in the caller yes
i guess if it's ior
down here it could be yes yes it's
probably std
global results yes exactly so this one
is actually a specific result type
if you don't have results
then you create an enum with one
tag i o error one tag
division error one tag whatever
you could do that yes
yeah it's very hard to maintain i've
tried various strategies i have
something that i think work pretty well
by defining actually defining the error
type and the result in the package that
uses it but it's cumbersome in some
cases so
yes correct but the good thing here is
actually this is explicit i think i find
c plus plus exceptions quite hard to
work around
there are all these examples where you
say okay here's a function how many exit
points do you have and then you have to
remember where every place can throw an
exception and that's not easy to follow
here it's quite clear
ownership and borrowing borrowing yes
this is the central part of of uh
rust essentially so it has a number of
concepts around ownership and checking i
don't know what the time is
just think of that okay
so i'll cover ownership and borrowing
and then if
we'll we can check checkpoint and see if
you want to see more or not
this is central to rust
so it's checked at compile time you
don't have a garbage collector if you
have a program that runs the risk of
actually losing data it will actually
error out at compile time except in some
cases there are always exceptions
arrays out of
indexing outside or an array is an
example
this is actually quite a good thing if
you review some piece of code if i
review c code i have to think about is
this a null pointer can it potentially
have a segmentation fault have you
released every memory you actually
allocated etc i don't have to care about
that i only have to care about the logic
of the program when i review rust that's
actually quite convenient
if it compiles there are basically never
any memory issues you don't have to
bother about that you can look at the
logic of the program
so this is quite convenient in my mind
so ownership every value has a single
owner
when the owner goes out of scope when
the function stops executing
or something
basically then the value is dropped so
you you delete it at this that point it
works like in c plus plus no surprises
there
ownership can be transferred you can
move things between functions
here's an example so we have a function
called show
it what it does is actually prints out a
dimension i have a type dimension
containing a width and a height
and it accepts
it as a
parameter and then you call it here and
you transfer ownership so you create the
dimension here
you pass it in and it is moved in
if you try to do something here it
doesn't work it generates an error
because you have you're trying to access
something that you don't own anymore
this is of course not always as useful
so in some cases you actually want to do
something this show function for
instance if you want to show
that i mentioned several times you don't
want to sort of recreate it every time
you you want to show it so you need to
have something else to actually work
with this and for this you have
references and references are similar to
pointers but not exactly the same and
i'll there are some semantic differences
there are pointers as well but they are
considered unsafe so pointers
just contain an address a reference is
more like a temporary handle to
something
when you are taking a reference you are
borrowing an access to it
so this is called a borrow
there are two types of borrows there is
a mutable borrow and it's an immutable
borrow so you can
if you have an immutable borrow you only
want to to read this
variable if you have a mutable borrow
then you actually want to change
something here you have two examples so
this is a
immutable borrow
where you only want to show it and here
you have a
mutable borrow where you actually want
to change the dimension
and you use it like this you pass in you
create your data you scale it in this
case you take immutable reference
and then you can show it as well
and you can call this any number of
times and it keeps track of that
anything
unclear any questions
just wonder if
uh what's the point of
you could have just had that borrowing
by default
so why do you have
why did they choose for the explicit uh
like ampersand to say
yeah movies
i mean what's the problem with having
borrowed by default if that's because
you usually think if
like a read-only borrow is pretty low
impact it shouldn't affect
because they usually they they decided
to have move as default
so
but they could have allowed the function
to define like this function does uh
really borrow and don't have to put that
it's going to do that okay yeah they
could have done that they decided not to
i think they want to be very explicit
about things i think that's the key
reason but it's not entirely true
anymore because there are some subtle
costs happening in the language so i'm
not sure it actually holds value anymore
but i think that was the original reason
plus i guess you have a lifetime things
to come to that
is more
yeah but if you had this function what i
think his point is is that if you had
this function it takes a reference you
have declared that it takes a reference
you don't need to add the data there if
you have an implicit conversion to a
immutable borrow you could have that in
the language they haven't but you could
have
yeah
exactly so they they do it does work in
some cases
it differs actually um
i think i i i'm not fully up to date on
the actual memory model but it actually
is both on stack and on heap so it's not
entirely clear-cut
so it is um
i i would have to read up on it and
actually have a separate presentation
but i guess that must be adjustable to
to be able to run without the
murder
yes so it does use stack for the for
most of it but it's not that way the
rest of the seven slides please put the
questions to the ends
okay as far as you can tell there's a
bug because you declare data that's
immutable but then you get a mutable
reference to it but you can't do that
right
yeah that's right so
good catch yes
it is a bug
sorry
uh yeah it would i don't i guess i
haven't compiled this so
um
so there are a number of rules for
borrowing
so
and the idea is that the borrowing rules
should be sufficient to prevent data
races in data races they distinguish
these from
normal races because you can actually
have data races in single threaded
programs i've run into them they usually
happen when you have destructors running
in different orders
and then you can have a race between
different areas of the code that
actually release memory in in strange
areas i i've run into it it's
hard to find
it rejects programs with dangling
references so you shouldn't be able to
have that at all
and you shouldn't have to have a garbage
collector that's the key points of the
rules and they are
you have a single mutable arrow a single
mutable borrow of a value or
you can have one or more immutable
borrows of a value
and the lifetime of a borrow may not
exceed the lifetime of the owner
so it keeps track of the lifetime of all
the owners all the time
and these other rules so
it's not strictly reference counting as
you you asked about but it's close to
that
yeah um
this is a compile thing
not a runtime thing
so it it deduces the lifetime
and the borrows at compile time it
doesn't actually need to have any
reference
helpers nope all right
no
yeah there are reference counted
objects as well but they are used for
linked lists and
complex graphs and similar things but
not
this is not what it covers
it's possible yes i'm i'm not sure what
you are what case you're actually
thinking about but you can deduce it at
compile time and you are being
conservative so this is sort of if it is
possible that you could have a
overlapping lifetime or it out of
lifetime then it's not okay
okay so
iterators is another topic now i i
covered borrows and
ownership basically
uh
do should i continue i said please make
these lights here but i would like to
have further questions to the end
because we are running out of time
there are people working they want to go
home so okay
i have a few more slides but let's take
the questions at the end so one thing
that also exists in rust is iterators
you're familiar with this from c plus
plus no surprises there you recognize
most of it already here are two examples
it has a way to actually do functional
like programming
uh it has extensive support for
iterators and closures and here is an
example so you can use a for loop in
this case
uh you're using a for loop for
for actually iterating over vector
but you can actually do it more
efficiently so you can also have this
functional version where you actually
take the iterator
of the vector this allows you to iterate
over everything and then you map for
each element in the
vector you can actually map a function
to it to do something in this case we
add one and then the in this case it's
still lazy so it's sort of pending code
to execute
and then you terminate it with something
that terminates it so it can be a sum it
can be a collect in this case collect
actually constructs a container of some
sort
so this is an efficient way to actually
iterate over a vector
add one to it and then return that new
vector with
it this is thanks to
anonymous functions similar to lambdas
and also that you implicitly capture
variables so in this case i actually
haven't captured a variable but you
could have a variable inside here it
would be captured automatically
yes
so it has a bunch of functions too many
to to actually memory
sorry everything needed for functional
i'll find in the iterators yes for not
only in iterators but among other things
iterators so you have fold you have map
you have
more efficient ways of mapping map
mapreduce actually so you can sort of
return a list of lists and flatten it
in one step
you have a bunch of other functions so
you can chain iterators yes
okay cool you can chain it regions and
that's quite cool you remember the dot
product operator we had
it looked roughly like this um i have
removed the return there but it's this
is how it looks roughly you can actually
write it like this so you can sort of
chain everything and stack everything up
and this of course becomes completely
unreadable if you do it too heavily but
it's very efficient it's incredibly
efficient compared to this one
so it's it's a lot faster
uh i don't and you can see me
asking about this on stack overflow as
well it's called zero
overhead abstraction i think
yeah so the second one then is safe
right now because of the zip i believe
safe yeah it's safe
it's different
yes it's safe so it will just it will
come minimum number of yes so it will
actually be correct
the form function interface i can't i'm
not going to discuss it too much but you
can interface c and c plus plus it
basically looks like this you can
declare a function
and say that it should be exportable now
you can call it from c
and you can actually
do something here's main is actually
calling this one as as an external
function you can go the other way around
as well so you can actually call c from
rust too that is more involved but it's
doable
here's a more complex example
and in this case i'm actually calling a
c function from rust here you can see
how it looks
so p write already exists so
i'm just saying that hey i want to use
this function it's an external c
function
it exists somewhere and then you have to
link with the library and it will work
and as you see this is unsafe so i have
to
say hey i want to do something that is
actually unsafe please
allow me
and don't complain
this is quite useful when you want to
transform so mozilla used this to
rewrite a large code base i don't
remember what it was actually but they
did it stepwise so they worked from
sometimes from the bottom up we're
writing some basic functions in rust
sometimes the other way around some
pieces actually called z functions and
they manage to translate very large code
based stepwise by using the form
function interface